hello I'm Bob Shelly
of introducing for you Daniel Kahneman I
have to say for this is the this is one
of our open lecture series talks and
we've had very many illustrious people
in for these talks but this is the
biggest turnout ever and I'm trying to
understand why I think it has its really
testimony to Kahneman's amazingly wide
reach in his works that he has touched
every do not every most departments in
the university you can see his
influences in the Economics Department
in the management school in the law
school in the psychology department and
the political science department it's
really all over I was wondering if I
could quantify his influence on Yale as
an example of many other universities I
was reminded that he has two co-authors
here major co-authors Nathan November
and Shane Frederick but I think he
probably has other co-authors so I had
the idea I would look up Daniel Kahneman
and Yale on scholar.google.com and then
I'd find all of all of his co-authors
and I'd find all the Yale professors who
wrote papers citing Daniel Kahneman and
I got 8400 hits and there is practically
no living scholar but I could substitute
for Daniel Kahneman and get anything
like that so I think is real and
testimony to the strength of his work we
had an interesting discussion at lunch
he has one of the most to me interesting
life stories he was born in Tel Aviv
but then grew up in Paris and the Nazis
as you may remember occupied Paris and
they were not very nice to Jews living
in
Paris so he was 11 years old when world
war ii ended and survived by his family
hiding and moving and so remarkably
danny said at lunch i don't feel any
scars from that no emotional scars from
that experience any way to continue his
life story he would then move back to
israel and studied at the Hebrew
University in Jerusalem and there he met
his most major collaborator Amos Tversky
and the two of them are collaborated for
years and a lot of that work is reported
in Danny's new best-selling book
Thinking Fast and Slow which is a I have
it wrong not exactly right and it's a
New York Times bestseller in 35
languages again testimony to them it's
just the amazing reach of his work it's
very powerful of work that he's done
unfortunately Amos Tversky died at age
59 in 1996 and was unable to share the
Nobel Prize
although Danny generously shared hit
with him in words I should say something
about the lecture series this is one of
the Arthur Okun lectures and this was
this series was funded by an anonymous
donor who was an admirer of Arthur Okun
and Danny told me at lunch that he's an
admirer of Arthur of Arthur Okun was a
professor at Yale who died also at an
early age at 51
in 1980 he was the chairman of the
Council of Economic Advisers under
President Lyndon Johnson and I think I
looked through his works and I didn't
see much in common between Hogan and
Kahneman except that I think both of
them were people with a deep respect for
the
and the facts and the real world so let
me just conclude by saying that I'm good
Danny will speak for one hour I think
and that leave us a full half hour to
four questions and we have someone with
a roving mic this event is being
recorded so we try to get your questions
onto the microphone and so that everyone
can hear all right I'm bringing you
Danny Kahneman
I've been retired for some years and and
I'm specifically retired from talking at
universities because I haven't been
doing really novel research for the last
three or four years I've been busy
writing that book and I don't think
really that I can demyx who are not
doing you think should be talking but
but when you're approached by Bob
Shiller it's very very hard to say no so
I this I think it's just about the only
one of its kind that I'm giving this
year another attraction indeed was there
the idea of giving the oken lecture and
it's because Oken Arthur Okun played a
certain role in my life I am NOT an
economist as I'm sure many if not all of
you know I'm a psychologist in fact I
never had a class in economics but the
work that Amos Tversky and I did was
sort of picked up by some friendly
economists and it's really riding on
their work that I you know I got the
Nobel Prize largely because of their
work not so much because of what we had
done but because of the fact that it was
influential in economics my first
introduction to economics was a paper
that Amos Tversky sort of put on my desk
many many years ago and and I was so
struck by it by the first sentence that
I still remember it by heart and it said
and it said that the human agent of
economic theory is rational and selfish
and his tastes do not change today it
would be his or her but then it was his
days do not change and I remember being
utterly astonished because for a
psychologist these three propositions
just sound bizarre that people are
rational
selfish and their tastes do not change
and as it happens I've done some work
not not by design just by the kind of
accidents that that guide most people's
lives and research I've done some work
on all three of them on rationality on
selfishness and on tastes and how they
train there was a year in 1984 during
which the fellow who is now the Guru of
behavior economics Richard Thaler who is
also my best friend spent a year with me
in Vancouver where I was teaching at the
time and during that year one of the
things we studied we studied fairness
and we studied the role of fairness and
economic transactions and and that is
when this was 1984 Arthur Okun had died
I think in 1980 posthumously there was a
book of his was published called prices
and quantities and and in that book in
effect you know it might not have been
noticed by economists at the time but
but he was giving a big play we thought
- fairness and trying to explain why
markets do not clear that is why agents
and the some conditions do not take
advantage of all the opportunities that
are available to them to make profit and
when we we studied very much that
problem what are the constraints on
agents within the economic sphere which
are punished by somebody being labeled
unfair in the market and the whole
introduction to up so that was actually
the first economics book that I
seriously looked at and well the
introduction to our paper was all about
Arthur Okun and with
had said so that was certainly part of
what brought me here not be talking
today not about fairness but about
rationality and about rationality and
psychology and uh and for those of you
who have read my book you'll recognize
most of the stuff because today well
I'll tell you something else and I won't
ramble all the time and just rambling
now so when when writes a book at an
elderly age or at least when I write a
book at an elderly age because that I'm
the only case I know then very strange
things happens which is that you only
know what you wrote in the book I mean I
have forgotten absolutely everything
ever knew that I didn't write down that
comes from the combination of writing a
book and then giving lots of talks about
it and then all the examples that come
to my mind are from the book and I
really like them because one of the
rules that I do mention in the book is
that when something becomes thoroughly
familiar you like it more and more and
so it becomes very difficult to invent
new things I will talk really not about
rationality but about irrationality no
not about irrationality about imperfect
rationality I I don't like the word
irrationality because it conveys to me
you know frothing at the mouth and a lot
of things that I think are just not
descriptive of humans but it is a
thought that the theory of the rational
agent model which plays a central role
in economics and in other social
sciences the rational agent model is
built on the assumption that people are
that economic agents are rational or at
least or rational enough so that you can
assume rationality at the basis of a lot
of economic modeling and it in a way
this is obviously not true and everybody
knows it's not true
Amos Tversky used to say that all the
economists he knows are fully aware of
their spouse not being rational or
they're deemed not being rational but
when it comes to economic agents in
principle or in general then they assume
and and defend the assumption of
rationality I propose a very simple
diagnostic for imperfect rationality and
you know when when you look at a
judgment or at a preference you can
represent it as a some combination of
considerations each of these
considerations is assigned some kind of
a weight and you know it's a it's a very
general scheme for representing
judgments and preferences and a failure
a perfect rationality and the broader
sense is that the weighting is not quite
right that is that there are some
considerations and some facts that are
given too much weight more than they
should have and I'm not going to define
what is the correct weight because that
depends on a lot of things and and there
are many ways of defining correct
weights but once you define a correct
weight in an acceptable way then it
turns out that people don't use those
weights don't apply those week's
considerations are over weighted or
underweight and this is when I think
convenient way of thinking about
failures of rationality most of the
familiar demonstrations of failure
rationality or this kind you know we
commonly assumed and recognize that we
people overweight the present over the
future they overweight losses over gains
they when they look at lottery tickets
that specify an amount to be won and you
know that the probability is menu skew
people overweight the amount rather than
the probability and they find those
lottery tickets to attractive more
attractive than they should if they were
perfectly rational people overweight
information that is currently available
over information that they do not have
so information that I need but don't
have gets much no less weight than
information that I do happen to have
people overweight emotional factors over
dry factors they they overweight vivid
examples over more pallid statistical
description people underweight certain
things and actually one very general
characteristic of the way that people
think it is that people underweight
statistical characteristics of our son
they tend to think about individual
cases and they focus on individual cases
they think about individual cases and
that is the source of that's been the
occasion for doing a lot of research
demonstrating different ways in which
people diverge from rationality there
are there are other Diagnostics
and you know I mentioned three of them
one that Amos Tversky and I did a lot of
work on is violations of the rule that
is called rule invariance and in it the
invariance rule specified that certain
factors should be given a weight of zero
so for example if you describe Kolkata
meat as being 20% fat or 80 percent fat
free in terms of the substance of what
you are saying you are saying exactly
the same thing and if people were
assigning the monetary value to
acquiring such a piece of piece of such
me then they should not be influenced by
whether it is described as 20 percent
fat or 80
in fact freak they are influenced by
that
so they overweight something that they
should neglect the content the meat
itself in this case is invariant but
it's described in different ways
you should be indifferent to these ways
you should not be affected by them but
in fact all of us are so this is one
family of violations of rationality
there is another which i think is
extremely important and this is that we
tend to focus on on the problem at hand
and we tend to focus very narrowly on
the problem at hand and you know this
takes the form of investors deciding on
a particular investment and very
frequently without regard for their
other investments or for what else they
are people making a decision without
considering the fact that there will be
further decisions in the future that you
know they should be considering what
they will do then when deciding what to
do now and it turns out people actually
don't then there are failures of what I
call a brick tivity and that's that one
isn't discussed a lot but it's quite
straightforward we we tend to think
about reasoning as going from premises
to conclusions so reasoning is
directional there are certain thing that
you assume and then from those
assumptions you get somewhere uh and
it's supposed to be directional when you
see influences that go the other way
that is when people believe in arguments
because they believe in the conclusions
that is a very characteristic failure of
perfect rationality and it's one that we
very commonly find now there has been a
lot of work along those lines
documenting these types of these types
of violations of the rules of the
perfect rationality
and economists in particular complain
and I think rightly so about the work of
psychologists in this area and they
accuse us quite correctly of not having
a theory economists are theories
psychologists don't in fact you could
say without exaggeration that economists
are theories and psychologists tend to
have lists they have lists of phenomenon
and you know long list of phenomena and
this is not considered elegant in some
circles and among my economist friends
it is not viewed kindly what
psychologists do have and it is true we
really do not have a general theory we
do have a lot of what I would call
intermediate level generalizations where
facts that are not very limited facts
they they have a certain range but they
are not linked very closely to each
other they there isn't a body of theory
to hold all of us together now when I
settle down to write a book on Thinking
Fast and Slow it's in a way an attempt
to go a little beyond what we have in
psychology in general but by trying to
take a lot of phenomena and trying to
put them within a single unified frame
now the framework I must say is nothing
to be proud of it's in fact a somewhat
disreputable approach what the one that
I have taken and I've taken it very
deliberately I speak in the book of two
agents in the mind and speak of system
one and system two as if they were
things and actually and if they were
persons because I'm trying to endow them
with a certain character with
with propensity is with skills with
habits with things that they tend to do
or are unable to do so that's the way I
go at it now I really don't believe that
there are such agents in the mind this
by the way it's contrary not only to the
rules of economics because it's not a
proper theory it's actually contrary to
the rules of doing proper psychology
because psychologists learn not to
explain behavior by assuming little
people inside the head they're called
they're called homunculus and you try
not to explain the behavior you know at
the agent by by the population inside
their head and I do precisely that and I
and I do it without shame and I will
tell you why I do it I will speak of
system one and that's that's the quick
one that's thinking fast
that's the intuitive one and I'll try to
describe it and I'll speak a system to
that's a slow thinking of the title this
is the control one this is the careful
one and and I'll speak of their
interaction as if they were interacting
and sort of one of them trying to
control the other and vice versa and of
course I don't believe that there are
such systems in the brain or you know
that there are these little people so
why do I do it well I'm going to tell
you the correct way of describing
everything that I'm going to say when I
say system one does X or system two does
exosystem two cannot do X what I really
mean by that is well that classes of
behaviors are classes of mental
activities that you could call type one
and type two psychologists have
absolutely no directions about chorong
classes of behavior type one and type
two now when I say that system one does
all the behaviors that are type one and
system two does all the behaviors type
two so I've invented an agent why have I
invented an eight-room you're going to
find out actually within the next hour
and I am quite sure that I'm
this makes it easy to think about
psychology by because our minds appear
to be wired for processing information
about agents we're just very very good
at endow in ages
you know animal-human a 10 down agents
with traits with propensities with
skills and once we have endowed an agent
with a propensity or whether trait we
tend to remember that and eventually
when we have a rich description of an
agent that agent does develop a sort of
personality and then we are able in
intuitive ways of guessing how that
agent will behave in other circumstances
this is really I believe is some thing
that we have that is built-in that we
can do and I'm deliberately building on
that this is a way I think I think of
system 1 and system 2 I can translate
that into proper language type 1 and
type 2 anytime so could you buy a lot I
think you know that unless you're trying
to impress some purists it's not worth
the effort you can just go on thinking
in terms of system 1 and system 2 and
the psychodrama
between them so let me tell you a bit
about the to system I'll start with
system to system - that's the slow one
and basically listen you can think of it
as the system that engages in effortful
activity so type 2 activities if you
will are activities that demand effort
now how do we know the demand ffs well
there are two main tests one is
physiological there are many
manifestations of effort including
dilation of the pupil heart rate
quickens lots of things happen that you
can tell when people are exerting mental
F and the main diagnostic is that when
people exert effort
one activity they cannot perform other
activities at the same time so you know
if my my diagnostic is if it is
something that you cannot do while
making a left turn into traffic
then it's effortful because when you
make a left turn into traffic you stop
talking and if people have any sense
we're sitting next to you they stop
talking and that's why speaking on the
cell phone is so dangerous when you
drive it's because the people who talk
to you don't know that you are
overtaking a car or that you're making a
left turn onto traffic so effort is we
have what is called a limited capacity
for effort which means that if we do one
thing there are other things that we
cannot do we cannot do several effortful
things at the same time efforts or
activities are experienced by and large
as my activities that is there is an
impression a feeling of agency attached
to most of these efforts will give 'ti
that's something that I do and so
multiplying two numbers is effortful
focusing intently on a particular spot
and try not to let attention wander
that's effortful being polite to
somebody that you don't like that's
effortful we we know about these things
because they train the physiology they
leave people tired and there is it there
are many indications that when people
are tired after exerting effort they
find it more difficult to exert effort
in other activities so this is what
system 2 does and by and large when we
think of our minds we think of what
system 2 does we think of ourselves
thinking people as the liberal
people as going in an orderly way from
one state of mind to another and of
making choices and making decisions and
of being quite conscious because you
know what goes on unconsciously well
we're not conscious of so the little
that we see about our internal life
that's multi-system - and we that's a
thesis of the book truly we greatly
exaggerate the importance of system - in
our lives and in human affairs in
general now in a system one those are
the fast thinking of the title of
Thinking Fast and Slow and mostly I'll
talk about one aspect of system one
which is memory you know we have that
marvelous organ between our ears it
makes sense of the world
second-by-second so that anything that
happens sort of understand we we get the
right ideas about it
we anticipate what comes next all of
this happens you know courtesy of that
thing that we have or associative memory
it creates an interpretation of the
world as we go so I see that scene you
see me this is really not something that
we choose to see I don't choose to see
you it happens to you and this is the
characteristic experience that is
associated with system one with
automatic activities they happen to you
you don't do them they happen and so
events and stimuli from the outside
world that create sensations
automatically they evoke memories
automatically so you know if I say 2+2 a
number came to your mind you didn't have
to ask for it you didn't have to decide
to perform that computation you couldn't
help carrying out that computation to
save your life anymore
then you could help yourself from
reading a word
bilbo adjust those things happen but
system one doesn't merely call for you
know well learn associations of this
kind if I ask you well do you think it
was really for preordained
that World War one could occur would
occur and for those of you who know
anything about the history of World War
one this instantly brought a lot of
information to mind that happened
automatically you didn't ask for it we
have not only an interpretation of the
world as it exists but we we can call
out complex stories that would take a
long time to unto the scribe and in a
way they all come at once so you know if
I ask you what are the chances of any
changes in the filibuster in the next in
the rules of filibuster in the next ten
years
something will happen will happen to you
you know fair amount about verse now
articulating it will be effortful but a
lot will happen without your having to
think about and these things really
happen very fast and my my favorite
example which is of course in the book
is of I won't try to imitate it it's
it's a male voice speaking in an upper
class British accent and and sing a
sentence and the sentence while the
individual events in that individual
brain are recorded continuously so
that's that's the background that's a
story the sentence is I have launched
tattoos all down my back it takes about
a third of a second
and you get a characteristic brain
response and the characteristic brain
response is surprise and it has a clear
signature if you think about what it
takes for someone to be surprised by
such an event it is be extraordinary
you've got to identify the voice as an
upper class British voice you've got to
bring up the stereotype of upper class
British man you've got to bring up the
idea that it's unlikely that many of
them have lodged the tools down their
back that is an incongruity hence the
surprise and that is detectable within
less than half a second this is amazing
and that is that is system one all of
this happens you know unbidden you don't
have to think about it it just happens
to you and a lot of complicated things
like that system one is not dumb so you
know we tend to think of system two at
the higher system but what we do really
well we do with system one because
skills our system one so driving when we
drive it's almost effortless except when
we take left turns into traffic or
overturn cars on a narrow road almost
effortless you can talk when you drive
but so that system one it's a
complicated activity and it is an
activity that we perform almost without
effort and automatically and there are
many such activities there are intuitive
skills we're very impressed by intuitive
skills we're impressed by the skills of
firefighters and chess players
and-and-and
great diagnosticians but all of us are
very health skills at that level and
many of them especially in the social
domain we can recognize each other's
moods we can serve someone you are tired
you know I you can recognize how spouses
move from one word on the telephone and
you know many other things are that
general nature so the skills are in
system one in that automatic memory
system that interprets the world so our
mind what we think of as oh my the real
products of our mind most of it is
system what most of it happens through
events that are experienced passively as
you know my memory provides that
information then we do something with it
we articulate it we respond with it we
we elaborate on it and that tends to be
system - so what's the image that I'm
drawing here
many people have two systems and
psychologist Jonathan Titus had a very
similar idea and he speaks of the
elephant and the rider I I propose
another image and it's theme of a
reporter or actually a whole bunch of
reporters and an editor and the
reporters are system one and the editor
is system 2 and what happens if the
reporter provides stories and the
stories are ready-made but they haven't
been approved yet they haven't been
endorsed yet and then there is the
editor the editor is busy but the editor
just has time to have a quick look at
the story and if it's okay it goes to
print it gets endorsed and a lot of what
system 2 does in my view is endorse
system one and then impressions oh you
know vague impressions become beliefs
and and so the vague tendencies become
decisions there are there is a lot that
happens when system two becomes involved
but the the action in many of these
cases comes from system one now so in
many cases the editor just you know
checks the story in it off it goes it
gets in those in some cases the editor
stops the story and either for a minor
rewrite or completely suppressed we'd
better not publish this that happens a
lot you know if youth talking with
someone and you know you have that
irresistible thought that this is a real
idiot
it's unlikely that you are going to say
it so and it by the way effortful not to
say it in some cases so this is system
to then a different assistant to and and
it's the editor suppressing something
quite often the editor may say well
let's have another story let's have
another take on this oh let me reason
very slowly and then you have the editor
himself or herself going over the story
and and recreating it so that's now that
system one and let me add something else
about that editor very central
characteristic of system to system two
is really lazy and and does it is really
governed by a rule of least effort and
there is a lot of evidence to that
effect now there are larger individual
differences in how lazy system one is
system two is it's much lazier for some
than for others and my best example
comes from someone who is not of a lazy
mind but
my best example you'll see comes from
someone in the audience frame Frederick
and he has an example that this doesn't
sound right Shane I apologize what I
meant to say that train came up with a
very good example and the example which
I'm sure many of you familiar with
there's a puzzle and the puzzle is the
following a bat and a ball together a
cost the dollar Tim the bat costs a
dollar more than the ball how much does
the ball cost and the beauty of this
example is that a number comes to
everyone's mind it's 10 cents and this
is this is an associative reaction and
you know most people will including
those who don't say thin cents
ultimately you know that's the first
response that comes to mind
the second beauty of this exactly that
10 cents is wrong and that it's very
easy to see that incense is wrong
because you know it's a bat if the ball
cost 10 cents then the bat costs a
dollar and 10 cents a total is 120 so
that's false
now I don't know the proportion at Yale
but I suppose you know it couldn't be
higher than at Princeton so about about
50% of Princeton students get that wrong
in writing in a written test they dress
18 cents now this is I think a very
important discovery and it's an
important fact because there is
something basic that you know about
everybody who wrote then since they
didn't shake you know if they had
checked they would have left it blank
they would have found the correct
solution which is 5 cents if you're
still working on it
well they would have done something else
something else with the power so system
two is really does as little as possible
so that's a sort of the image that I'm
proposing you have those two systems
system two is in control it can suppress
like an editor you know not now another
tool or not the story let's do something
else let's recompute but by and large
the action comes from system one
proposing suggesting having impressions
having feelings and become emotions that
become intentions and become decision
that become beliefs and if we want to
understand how the mind works actually
it turns out that we have better
understand what are the operating rules
a system one and I have already said
something uh that well this by the way
before I go on there is a basic
heuristic that you can follow in trying
to predict behavior doesn't always work
heuristics don't always work but it it
works a fear amount of the time which is
to ask what is the first reaction what's
the first reaction to a situation to a
problem to a word the first reaction is
very diagnostic the first reaction in
the system one reaction it's the first
emotion it's whether you approve or
disapprove it's whether you want to
approach or avoid there are many things
that happen instantly withdraw the first
reaction and and either that first
reaction will be carried over directly
into beliefs and actions and so on or it
will be it will provide the anchor for
what happens next
so that even if it is not really
endorsed it is still influential even a
system to
the editor has assigned somebody else to
rewrite the story something of the
original story is still there and so as
a as a heuristic it's a useful to
university now let me talk about about
the operating characteristics of system
1 and what I will do is mainly focus on
characteristics that explains failure
perfect rationality
I think of system 1 as a story teller
and I'm using a lot of metaphors but by
storytelling what I mean is system one
sees connections between events and you
have to think of it AB memory as you
know vast network of ideas which are
linked associatively which are linked
not by mere associations but by specific
links from cause to effect and from
token to type and and what we have with
that machine
it looks for connections and it does
this automatically one of my best
examples is when I learned from the same
fella bits in its in the Black Swan and
and it talks about Bloomberg News on the
day that Saddam Hussein was captured and
I don't recall the exact sequence but at
one stage the bond market went up and at
that stage the headline very big
headline was Saddam Hussein creates
fears in the markets or reduces the bond
market goes up then the bond market went
radically down and there was a story
Saddam Hussein your capture reassures
the public the bond market
what happens this is completely
difficult you have a fact and the fact
is something happened in the market it
went up or it went down it looks for an
explanation in memory there is a search
for an explanation the explanation that
has to be an event that is possibly
potentially causally related and that
happened earlier and that is
sufficiently salient and surprising to
be the cause
now here you get the bond market doing
something and anything that was going to
happen to the bond market that day was
going to be attributed to saddam hussein
because that was an event which was
surprising and sort of consequential and
that's the way it works so we tend to
tell stories those stories we don't even
have to tell them they occur to us
in that way the world comes interpreted
and it comes interpreted in causal terms
this emphasis on causality I can't
emphasize causality enough because it
really is a characteristic and the way
that the system works looking for causes
inferring causes and and working from
causes forward so it tells stories then
there is something else that happens
that is a characteristic of system one I
think which is that it tells the best
possible story so it tells a story that
is coherent and I call that associative
coherence it makes sense makes sense in
that you know it makes sense for an
individual to be all good or all bad we
really don't like the idea of Hitler
loving little children or flowers though
in fact he did this this bothers us
because it is not emotionally consistent
it is not associative we consistent we
tend to look for stories that have that
form of consistency
and coherence now you can make a
coherent story from very little
information in fact the less information
in some cases the easier it is to make a
coherent story now what matters here is
that subjective confidence the comfort
that people have appears not to be
determined by the amount of information
the confidence that people have in their
impressions and the stories that the
system one is telling them confidence is
determined by the associative coherence
of the story by whether the story makes
it internal sense if we have a good
story we feel confident in it it's the
internal contradictions that lower our
confidence this is radically different
from the rational way of assigning
probability or to an event or to a story
or to a hypothesis when we rationally
assign a probability to hypothesis we
weigh the evidence but here it's not
about the evidence it's about the
internal coherence it is really not
about the amount of evidence we see that
all over the place and research radical
insensitivity to the size of samples
radical insensitivity to the overall
amount of evidence we have I've
described it as a machine for jumping to
conclusions and the you know the example
really unfortunate that I can't think of
any other one but you'll be able to
think of another one
I asked somewhere about someone who is a
national leader and that national leader
is intelligent and firm now is is she a
good one and actually you have an answer
intelligent infer that's really good
you're already there you have an answer
you have an answer as you go you're
evaluating it now you know if the third
would have been corrupt you'd change
your mind but the first two words and by
the way you wouldn't change your mind
enough because it would have been worse
if I had first said that she's corrupt
and then intelligent and ferb that makes
it worse then intelligent and firm makes
corruption worse we jump to conclusions
we form immediate impressions on the
basis of very little evidence
this will cause a failure of perfect
rationality and many failures have that
character system one tends to suppress
ambiguity and not to recognize ambiguity
so I have many examples of that but when
I use most often is an approach the bank
and when you hear an approach the bank
most of you think of the bank as as a
financial institution but if the
previous sentence have been something
about floating down the river the word
Bank would mean something else and
they're really the sentence and approach
the bank is ambiguous the ambiguity is
suppressed most of you are supposed see
more banks and rivers and you decide I
mean something gets decided you don't do
it it happens to you and big you it is
suppressed the solution is adopted and
this is very characteristic of system 1
so there is a suppression of ambiguity
and telling the best story possible this
has important implications it has
implication that we live in a world that
is radically simpler than the real world
they simplify the world as we construct
stories about now I spoke of associative
coherence and let me develop that a
little bit
and I already mentioned something that
psychologist called the halo effect
which is that the various traits that we
assigned to an individual or to a group
or to a society tend to be emotionally
coherent they tend to make sense
together in emotional terms but there
are other manifestations so here is an
experiment the experiment in the
experiment people are required to
evaluate the validity of a line of
reason the validity of the cylinders and
the syllogism
is all roses or flowers some flowers
fade quickly therefore some roses fade
quickly valid or invalid it is not valid
for those who are still working on it
ah there it is not valid because it's
entirely possible that all the flowers
that fade quickly are not roses but it
is true that some roses fade quickly now
I forget the exact number but it's well
over 70% of undergraduates
say the reasoning is valid this is
enormous ly important of the finding
because it tells us something about
about the way we think in in politics
for example we have a conclusion the
conclusion is true we believe that the
conclusion is true and that is enough to
make us believe in arguments that favor
that conclusion this is a violation of
what I call objectivity here the
reasoning goes the wrong way from
conclusion to this characteristic
it explains something which seems at
first to be the opposite of jumping to
conclusions it is why in a serious sense
it is really almost impossible to change
people's minds about things that matter
to them and if you ask yourself why you
believe in what you believe be it in
religion or in global warming or you
know whatever else you believe why do
you believe it we have been socialized
to think that we believe in things
because there's evidence to support them
but this is not the way that we actually
form beliefs we believe in these things
because we trust other people who
believe in them that's the main reason
you know we have religious beliefs it's
not you know we are not waiting for
evidence to have those beliefs it but
what there is is there is an emotional
connection a powerful emotional
connection between love and trust and
belief and and other people believing
and what what is really very important I
think I had the occasion to speak about
that to the National Academy of Sciences
why why there is difficulty in conveying
scientific evidence to the public that
scientists tend to think that we believe
in things because there is evidence to
support them this is not the way that
most people believe in things actually
it's not even true of all scientists
always but it certainly is not true of
the public's that scientists are trying
to address evidence really doesn't seem
to work and why evidence doesn't seem to
work seems to be because evidence does
not resume the kind of evidence that you
know scientists brain does not resonate
very well
system one system one needs stories
preferably stories about individual
cases preferably clear causal stories
that have emotional impact it's very
unfortunate in a way but that's the way
I think things are so what makes us the
same system one that makes us jump to
conclusion when there is very little
evidence makes us extraordinary
resistant to change not when there is a
lot of evidence but when there is an
ingrained collection of attitudes and
emotions and beliefs they are going to
be held even against massive opposing
evidence another characteristic of
system one
when we ask people a question they tend
to do more than we asked them to do and
there was an experiment
most forty years old that had a big
impact on me
where people listen to words on speakers
and they were asked to make a rhyming
judgments to the words rhyme or not and
here are two pairs of words and one is
vote note they write and the other is
vote goat are they rhyme too but people
are much slower saying that both goat
rhymes then vote note so what did they
do they heard the word they spelt it and
the mismatch on the spelling slowed them
down in detecting the match on the
rhyming they did something entirely
superfluous or a computation was done
which was entirely unnecessary this is
the way that the system works it works
in parallel it generates not
sequentially like orderly reasoning but
a lot of things happen in parallel and
that one question evokes much more than
one answer in the same way people are
asked about the syllogism is it valid
but what happened was that system one
immediately detected it is true it is
true and true and valid or associatively
correlated and it's that correlation
that caused people to answer the
question valid incorrectly by the way
the same undergraduates who fail the
question about roses if you formulate
exactly the same question in terms of
X's and Y's they answer it with no
difficulty whatsoever incorrectly most
of them
so it's it is the case that when an
incorrect answer comes very readily to
mine incorrect answer being a correct
answer to an into a different question
we tend to adopt that and we answer
questions that we haven't been asked
this turns out to be quite an important
mechanism in judgment and in
decision-making
I'll give you well I have time maybe for
both examples but at least one okay I'll
take uh I I speak of a young woman named
Julie and she is a graduating senior and
I'm going to tell you one fact about
Julie which is that she read fluently
when she was four and now I'm asking you
what's a DPA right the striking thing is
that actually although you may be
embarrassed to admit it a number came to
your mind and you have an idea for GPA
on the basis of that information no it's
not precise but you know it's certainly
over more than 3.2 and it's seen on less
than 3.9 and you know it's actually
agreement on those kinds of things is
remarkably close because we're in a same
culture and we understand each other now
we absolutely I think understand the
mechanism that creates this impression
and the mechanism is that when we hear
she read fluently at age 4 we have an
impression of how precocious she was now
we would ask how precocious was Julie
there are us what's a GPA now 20 years
later or something but you can go from
the answer to one to the answer to the
other
directly and it turns out that people's
answer to what sorry PA her GPA is about
as extreme as the judgment of how
precocious she was in in her reading
that's the way that people do this do is
not the right word that's the way that
things happen in people's mind we have a
matching rule and people out you know
you could you could match Julie's
reading age to a lot of things you know
like two how many how tall a building
would be as tall you know in New Haven
would be as tall as Julie as Julie's
reading speed people will give you a
number of a number of rules for that
building that is a fundamental ability
of system one and one that is often used
to answer questions okay let me bring
this to a close I could you know it's
it's a long book and you know I could go
on and on but but I think I think you
get the point that I'm trying to make
which is that we have an absolutely
wonderful mind I mean you know it's just
incredibly marvelous what it can do you
know it can learn to drive it can learn
to identify you know that that the
particular combination of a voice and a
statement is surprising it can do lot of
great things it can provide an immediate
diagnosis it can it can identify very
good mood interest in intuition in short
as possible intuition is marvelous but
we also has an other mind that is really
incompatible with the basic requirements
of rationality as put forward you know
as explained in decision theory you the
basis in we can
it is we have a mind that is not
equipped for invariance because your
reaction to fat-free or to fat food is
not going to be the same it is the mind
that is not equipped for dealing
adequately with quantity of evidence
because we tend to make up stories and
evaluate the coherence of these stories
and so the the verdict is really not a
negative verdict than the human mind
it's a complicated verdict but it's
clear that the theory of rationality
within decision theory or within the
standard models of what rationality
should think of is profoundly non
psychological the psychological truth
you know we don't know the truth but
what I try to summarize in this book is
not compatible with the rational model
what I presented to you is not a theory
but I hope it's a little bit on the way
to a theory that that there is some
internal coherence to the story that
I've been telling you and so even if the
story is not good if it is coherent you
might believe it if I so thank you
and I say we are having a reception
right out there at 5:30 and a half 25
minutes for professor Kahneman meanwhile
we have someone with microphones if you
ask a question could you identify
yourself first movies mental to the line
or do you want to have a lot I think
they might have teller getting out
my name is Mike I'm the townie in New
Haven you spoke of a wide range of free
reactions of laziness using system to
and I wonder if that applies to the wide
range of people making momentous
decisions some people can decide to buy
a house and perhaps go too fast and some
people just can't ever make up their
minds yeah I mean that there certainly
of large individual differences and
actually Shane Frederick who who studied
the bat and ball problem has also
studied the implications of individual
differences turns out that people who
trek themselves and who don't check
themselves are different people there
probably is an optimum between analysis
and paralysis that has to be sought and
you know this is the holy grail for many
people who deal in management theory is
is to find how much analysis in the
proper is a proper amount and when and
when is there time to decide and there
are there differences in situations some
situations you know require quick
decisions and they are largely
individual differences my name is Craig
I'm an economics student here and my
question well you and Amos obviously
pioneered a lot of this behavioral
economics work currently what I've seen
is the application of this work to
policy especially Thaler and Sunstein
they're very big promoters of applying
what you've been able to find to policy
where do you see behavioral economics
going in the future in 5-10 years what
what are the advances that we're looking
for well thanks for the comment I think
it is true that the great successes of
behavioral economics in recent years
have been in the domain of policy
suggesting interventions and gasps
dictator and cass sunstein
call that libertarian but all those
interventions that make it easy for
people with a lazy system to to make
decisions that tend to be good true and
that's the main instrument but not the
only one is manipulation of default so
if you make it the default that say
unless you check a box or unless you do
something your organs will be donated if
you died in an accident the rate of
donations will be very high if you make
a default that you don't know me and you
have to track or do something in order
to donate the rate of donations will be
the difference is somewhere between you
know 90% and 18% was a huge effect I
should add that this work is absolutely
not a continuation of the work that they
were still seeing I did Amos Tversky and
I did work on rationality primarily dick
Thaler adopted that work and sort of
made it popular and may behave your
economics possible with it he
contributed really the notion of what he
calls bounded self control that he adds
to bounded rationality and most of the
nodules they work on the boundary
between rationality and self-control by
allowing people to be lazy to make a
decision you ask me about the future
well I I can proudly say I have no idea
I have no idea because you know you know
that behavior economics as a future at
least shorter and that you know because
very very good students are taking that
as a field for graduate work and that
mean that they're committed to that
field for 10 or 15 years so that future
is guaranteed what they will do with
their time I don't know but because they
are very good students of good
University is very likely they'll do
interesting things what those
interesting things are I have no idea
that we know what would be nice it would
be nice to be able to do economics with
behavioral economics I mean it would be
nicely which you know it would be nice
to have sort of a you know an idea for
markets behave and so on which I don't
think at the moment we really do it's
more behavioral economics is still about
individuals and about some phenomena
that are ruled by the behaviors of
individuals when it comes to markets I
think there is a long way to go
I'm sure that there are people working
on it now I hope successful I don't know
of any major successes until now the big
successes behavior economics actually I
asked my friend Nick Saylor and as I
said the Guru of behavior economics what
I called him a couple of days ago and I
said look I mean I'm in a panic I'm
going to Yale I'm going to have to talk
to people vague through the economists
what do I say what's happening in
behavior economics and he sent me to a
paper by an economist and he made a big
point of that who is a very very good
young economist but shetty who is at
Harvard and is not a behavior occurs
that is he doesn't describe himself as a
miracle but when he does stuff on
savings and tax and the impact of
taxation on encouraging savings it turns
out that he uses behavioural notions as
a matter of course and that is the way
that we hope the field will develop big
fellow in saying that he hopes that the
world behavioral the word behavioral
will fall aside because all of economics
you know might become behave I'm a
psychologist so I don't I don't have
professor and going yeah I'm a nursing
student here so it's a great lecture but
I I have a little question so you said
it's not perfectly rational to favor an
argument if the conclusion is true that
correct am i I'm saying it is not
rational to infer from from the truth
yes I did but isn't that how signs work
like if we have some theory and we do
some result from this theory and if this
result is true
or it's closer to the observations and
we favor this theory ah that's so long
what what would be wrong in the theory
in the context of theory would be to say
the facts must be this because they fit
the theory it would be to change what
you consider or not
or a fact to fit your fear and people
losers scientists certainly that's this
is what I am talking
oh poor husky sophomore cognitive
science student here I have a friend
overseas who's a big fan of yours he
made me buy him Thinking Fast and Slow
and bring it back to Prague as soon as
it came out and recently I talked to him
and I asked him how he was and he was
like terrible because he's double
guessing now every decision he makes
because of all the cognitive because of
all the kind of devices that you
introduced him to
I mean it's a solid list right there are
about 18 of those so my question is how
would you suggest that we efficiently
translate your cognitive biases research
into a more perfect personal rationality
because the checklist approach doesn't
really work well I don't want to speak
ill of your friend but he but he must
have had a predisposition for doubt
because many people have read the book
it's not the most common reaction my
my my suggestion is that you can read
the book and be completely safe it will
have no effect on you whatsoever it will
it may improve and I think it might
improve your ability to detect the
mistakes of other people and I have that
in mind in writing the book I call that
educating gossip and I think that
educating gossip is a very important
function because what is the case is
that we anticipate the gossip of other
people when we make consequential
decisions and if we anticipate
intelligent gossip we might make better
decisions and if we anticipate stupid
gossip and so making gossip more
intelligent is a worthwhile objective
and reaching the language I think is a
worthwhile trick and that's you know
that I don't think this is really
another self-help book and you know and
of course it's very easy for me to say
because I've been studying it's not only
I've read the book I wrote it
then they prove my thinking at all um my
name is uh this is for you my name is
Michael Alcon um huge fan of your work
read the book numerous times and um
everything that you just talked in the
book resonating everything pretty
because we're fairly clear there was one
part of the book which left me with
questions is the between page yeah I
actually have a whole list of notes with
hope bokya page 27 28 you said when
talking about prospect theory you said
that the one thing that prospect theory
cannot deal with is complex emotions
like we got in disappointment and
obviously these have an immense
influence on the way we perceive loss
and obviously you can predict the future
of next 10 years what's going to happen
in research but what do you think is the
next stage going beyond prospect theory
you know that what prospect theory is
you know more than 30 results so the
next stage is now and then there'll be
and and that there are elaborations on
prospect theory and clearly improvements
of it so Matt you rabbinic Berkeley has
published theoretical papers that
clearly enrich the theory so they enrich
the concept of what the consequences and
and they enrich the concept of utility
so that it's attached and usually it's
much richer than what we had in prospect
theory I'm not sure that it's going to
replace prospect theory because
basically what what happens and it's you
know it's luck when it happens it's not
prospect theory so great it's it's got a
couple of ideas that are really useful
and that people can apply to many things
and loss aversion being one of them and
I
you know the waiting from over waiting
it low probabilities being another and
those ideas are very useful and they are
going to go and being used what happens
next
I have no idea really impossible to tell
you know it was impossible to tell
before prospect theory that it you know
that it would work as it did are they
impacted dead and you know it would be
easy to imagine certainly if we publish
the same article word-for-word in a
psychological journal it would have had
no impact on economics so you know there
are many lot factors I have no idea what
I study is how we make decisions
unconsciously and from what I understand
your system one is about rapid
unconscious decisions and system two is
about slower conscious decisions but is
there a role for decisions that we make
unconsciously but over a longer period
of time I mean this there is a lot of
research going on at the moment on on
this issue of unconsciousness surgeons
it's quite on traversal among among
people in the field whether there is you
know the evidence is compelling that
people make better decisions on
consciousness or not some of my friends
believe yes and others believe now and
you know I'm not sure it's we can expect
some progress on that issue within the
next ten years because very good people
study and it's you know it's considered
an important topic but altogether the
issue of conscious and unconscious is
very controversial now and you know it's
a big topic and I have no idea where
psychology is going to be on those read
in those respects five or ten years from
now
I'm senior economic student here and my
question is about in your lecture you
spoke about how system 1 and to operate
on a micro level within the individual
human brain but throughout history and
whether or not these accounts are true
or not whole societies have been painted
as either thinking fast or thinking slow
the classical example of Athens and
Sparta comes to mind do you believe that
there are these broad cultural
distinctions and if so where do they
emerge from well this is really not my
field I would there are certainly
differences even within a cook you know
within our culture and within our
society there are class differences the
education effects on the relative weight
and and even I would say popularity at
system 1 lose the system to there people
are proud of making gut decisions and
they're people who are embarrassed by it
and there are cultures which value by a
lot in this culture for example we tend
to value decision makers who decide
quickly it's considered a sign of
competence concerns you lose points by
taking time so I can readily imagine
cultures in with that would not be the
case in with thinking carefully would be
valued but in this culture it is not so
I'm sure there are differences I don't
know enough to discuss them in detail
again here my name is Xander I'm a PhD
student in psychology I have a question
ever since my undergrad I've been I've
been familiar with with your work but
recently I I started reading books by um
gegege answer I'm not sure if you
familiar with him and and he kind of
came up the notion that many of these
biases and heuristics are evolutionary
adaptive right that millions of years of
evolution have taught us what you ristic
sworkit depending on what kind of
environment and that instead of weighing
pros and cons we should really be
thinking less in a way not thinking less
and using less information and kind of
relying on these biases and heuristics
actually can lead to better
decision-making so I was wondering if
because at least in economics it seems
that the view is kind of perpetuated
that the comment diversity biases
approach to judgment and decision making
that it's viewed as a bias that needs
correcting and my question was do you
really characterize your work as as
these things that the heuristics and
things that you've identified through
observation and experiment are things
that actually need correcting and then
whether it's okay for economics is to
take bits and pieces from psychology and
incorporate that into their model of
rationality well you should know the
background for those of you who don't
have been good gig render is not a fan
of my work
and we will sudden quarrel publicly so I
I don't really want to come in too much
uh I I I would say this I have presented
a story about system 1 and system 2 and
the way that memory works and from that
story heuristics are inevitable they
just you know something like that
must be the case that you will answer
their own question and that it will be
associatively related to the right
question and so on so I don't think that
the heuristics have been selected for
the mind that we have has been selected
for the heuristics are a side-effect of
a mind that we have and and to my mind
there is no evidence that anything else
is the case so the broader view that I
would see is let's look at you know how
the mind ghent why the mind generates
those heuristics and it turns out that
you know if if you have in mind that
computes more than it needs to then uh
then you will get URIs --tx and it's
it's sort of a very interesting debate
now for for the experts and I'll be very
brief there is a debate on whether
people the beauty of heuristics being
that they use little information this is
the point that good
has been making very eloquently my
observation on that is that there is
absolutely no need for the mind to focus
on little information because we're very
very good at digesting a lot of
information in peril so it doesn't need
to be fast and frugal if the mind is the
way it is then here is the way I
described it is if it is as I described
it then you're going to get heuristics
whether or not they were selected for
okay I'm Aaron Girdler I'm a sophomore
in a psychology major at the college I
thought that one of the saddest and
absolutely the funniest parts of
Thinking Fast and Slow was the time when
you and all the other researchers were
trying to create an Israel the
psychology textbook that would explain
this theory and you fell under the
planning fallacy and all fell apart
horribly so you've spent a lot of time
in academia and kind of various spots
along the line there are there any
things about the life in academia and
being an academic that bother you that
ways that you think the system could be
improved by applying your own systems to
it like what are the cognitive biases
within academia that you see
you know in a setting like that
responses are usually have to be
ready-made I don't have already made an
answer to your question if you ask me
you know what would I correct about
academic life it's a it's a slow topic
for me I would have to think slowly and
I I can't
there's no I my impression is that
thinking about thoughts and decisions as
products is a useful heuristic as there
are many places and that includes
committees and you know financial
institutions governments but actually
produce decisions when they produce
judgments and the idea that you could
impose some quality control and that
some ways of doing those things are
better than others that idea by itself
is not fully implemented and it's
interesting why does not and if anywhere
I would think it might be more readily
implemented in university than in other
places but I don't know how if the
conclusion is true becomes very very
easy to believe the rationality can
twist the rationale to support those
conclusions actually a Shan talked in
one of our classes about how if you
present something in a certain type face
italics versus non italics people are
more likely to believe it's true so in
terms of that sort of a lot of
traditional economics has become very
mad Mathematica Matta sized it's sort of
a version of physics mV
are you optimistic that despite you know
behavioral economics being a much more
true description of how people think and
make decisions that that will be able to
sort of suppress the system want
tendencies and most people who do
believe in traditional economics
right I don't have to answer this
because you know I'm a psychologist I
really and I don't have any clear ideas
of where psychology is going but I
certainly had no idea hi professor
my name is my name is Kevin I study
public health here and it seems like
decision making has gotten much more
informed over the last several years
right it used to be that kind of at
least organizational level decision
making was made by very few people and
now we have teams of analysts big data
computers helping with that decision
making and it seems like even at the
individual level there are more and more
of these decision making tools so do you
think kind of taking this step further
this proliferation of decision making
aids will ever lead us towards classical
economics towards the perfect ration
Harding alright I think that's a
development that we can see occurring
and I think that the silver bags will
improve the quality of the sir
there is for example the regulation
efforts of behavior economists such as
the castle state have been in the
direction of making easier for people to
make rational decisions for example by
enforcing that all mortgages to be
comparable to be reported and described
in terms that allow very quick and ready
comparison I think purchases of cars are
going to be you know the Internet is
certainly going to improve the quality
of this it is happening already it is
happening with Yelp it is happening you
know with with reviews and it's going to
happen so on that I think we can be
quite optimistic um my name is Robert
black I have a background in sociology
and economics um there are two social
sciences that emphasize the idea of a
rational actor economics and political
science and economics the idea of a
rational actor you know it generally has
an optimistic conclusion that is good
for society when people act in that
manner generally now in political
science so let's going to make that
statement but it leads me to ask why
does the rational actor act like the
irrational actor in the first place and
what can we learn from that knowledge
now what is it about human nature that
leads or brings people to act in the
manner of a rational actor and what can
we learn
if we ever could figure that out well
we have that idea of ourselves as
reasoning means reasonable games and so
certainly within this culture true there
are cultures where this is not the case
but within this culture along with many
other things that our value of the
ability to reason is valued so you know
we have contradictory values of you are
decision makers to decide quickly but we
also have want people to have good
reason to be able to defend their
positions so there is a pressure for
acting rational whether there is a
pressure for being rational I don't know
but there certainly is a pressure for so
forward to having defensible defensible
views the the view of you know the
pessimistic use of rationality is really
linked more with selfishness and with
rationality per se that is it's the idea
of relentless selfishness that play the
part I think in the pessimist
you